this episode of the honey boo is brought
to you by rate con upstart Oh max
cryofreeze and manscaped more on that
later let's get into the do the honey do
with Ryan Sickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
it's studio night pants I'm Ryan Sickler
Ryan Sickler calm on the website Ryan
Sickler on all social media make sure
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
guys so many of you already have but if
you want to watch the do every Tuesday
you got to go subscribe to my youtube
channel youtube.com slash our Sickler
we're starting to add time codes in the
post now too so if you've got a favorite
story from the episode you can go look
in the bottom of the post and there'll
be some time codes there where you can
jump right to your favorite part the
patreon show the honey-do with you all
I'm having a great time highlighting the
lowlights with you all had a few friends
come on first while we iron out kinks
and everything but he'll so far I've
talked to a guy whose father came out in
his 40s a girl who had two [ __ ] we
had we had a guy whose wife developed an
online video game addiction
I mean shitty parents we're getting all
of it right now and I love talking to
you guys about it so make sure you're
subscribed to the patreon show and send
your stories there's one place to send
your stories honey-do podcast at
gmail.com if you or someone you know you
think has a great story to share submit
it there we'll go through it and
hopefully eventually get John and do an
episode with you also make sure you're
subscribe to the Facebook fan page for
the honeydew and for Ryan Sickler we got
all the information coming at you over
there and then the website for the show
is the honeydew podcast com that's where
you can go find out everything and
anything about the honeydew
excuse me including the merch and I
cannot thank you enough night pants
nation we're growing we're growing we're
getting stronger and stronger
the mugs these mugs are actually just a
gift for every guest that comes on the
show but you guys have asked so much
that we're gonna get them in the merch
store they'll be up soon you can buy the
mugs you guys have also asked about the
gray hoodie eyewear it was just one that
I have but we're gonna put gray hoodies
up and night shorts you all keep asking
about night shorts
it's gonna happen night shorts are gonna
happen will be a night pants
nice shorts nation all right now if you
live in LA and you need musical
instruments or lessons for you or your
kids go to Santa Monica Music Center I
record here as you know their family
owned business been serving the
community for 50 years they're great
people and you can get online classes
right now from trained and Los Angeles
musicians all right not just guitar
lessons these guys there's plenty of
lessons you can get here all right
and if you go to Santa Monica music calm
right now and you use code honeydew they
will waive the registration fee and
they'll give you one free lesson when
you sign up for a package if you have
any questions there's a website or
excuse me a phone number on the website
feel free to call them and talk to them
as I always say ladies and gentlemen
these are the stories behind the
storytellers we're over here
highlighting the low lights and today
I'm super stoked to have this guest on
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Tommy Lee thanks good to see him it's
great to see you thank you for being
here yeah and also thank you for putting
up with me I came to do Britney's
podcast like a week ago and I was I
wanted a prop look I'm a respectful dude
I wanted to properly meet you as
Brittany's husband because I've known
Britt for ever and I was like it's a
pleasure to finally meet her husband and
then I was like get out of the way
Brittany let's sit here all right I
loved you and you you accepted it and I
have fruit that's awesome so thank you
for being here and we're gonna think
we're gonna have some fun but before we
do please write now promote everything
you got the new album out plug all of it
yeah
new record it's called and row these
there's two singles that are out now one
is called tops featuring push push South
African rapper who spits serious fire
and another track called knock me down
featuring kill vain witch
is a super super heavy almost screamo
rock wrap joint that's just you want to
break [ __ ] when you hear it it's one of
those yeah but in anyway um the singles
are out the album drops October 15th
okay I think I can get in that date
right and the reason the record is
called and row is because one side is
all male energy of the record oh okay
I'm talking old school like vinyl
although it is coming out on vinyl also
other side is all one sides female one
sides male and I remember just you know
trying to sequence the record you know
you got all this body of work done and
okay his track into this track okay
that's cool nah man that key doesn't
work I went into this track and I just I
spent forever trying to get it to just
play down really dope right and at some
point I just want you know what hold on
a second I just split split the female
energy and the male energy and kind of
let them kind of dance on their own
sides and they rent it just I was like
now it all makes sense and so that's
kind of where that that organically came
about because it wasn't what was my
intention
I love has that ever been done before I
don't not that I know is something he
said yeah quite may have done it but I
don't know that I've never heard of
anyone rate so it's cool so like
whatever vibe you're in there's
something for everyone on the record
it's really cool that's great man good
for you I love that you're still doing
how old are you now I am 57 57 do you
look great
thanks man any [ __ ] seven and I know
that drumming and being on tour is hard
work so you got to stay in shape so I
look I have a million questions but the
first thing I want to say is this like
you're my favorite drummer
I mean look I've been I love rest in
peace Neil Peart just passed around
Bonham was fantastic I was I'm a big
Mitch Mitchell fangs I just love Jimi
Hendrix you know there's so many good
drummers out
buddy miles I was a big buddy miles fan
but you I grew I came up with motley
crue I grew up on your music I remember
coming home every [ __ ] day in the
summer with home sweet home being number
one so long I but here come the girls
titties there's Tommy hey [ __ ] I
think they retired it because you were
so undefeated they were like we gotta
give somebody else a chance dismembered
nine years yeah MTV for like ever like
ever whoa yeah right give some miles
Kurt you guys been doing this for two
years it was on for like I felt like my
whole high school but the like you were
always this the this larger-than-life
figure in this rock band but then you
did that show Tommy Lee goes to college
ah and man I I was telling your manager
I loved it because you became like a
person to me that I was like oh because
the thing was you didn't and that's
where this pictures from University of
Nebraska where he went shoutout to
University of Nebraska yeah go go big
red and that's so rad and that agree
that's when Sakura and I were there it's
a kick field goals on your stadium I
could I could have helped you guys win
this year yeah but I remember thinking
also thinking like oh this will be a
cakewalk for him he's a [ __ ] drummer
he's gonna go drum in a marching band
what's the big deal and then watching
you struggle with that struggle with the
college like but you took it seriously
and you were frustrated you were
disappointed and embarrassed you weren't
like whatever I get to go back to LA and
play in [ __ ] Motley Crue yeah did you
like that I was like this dude's this
dude's awesome are you from Nebraska
no from Maryland okay yeah yeah I got
you I was just I thought there was some
other Association there um yeah that you
know I typically wouldn't do a show like
that just something that you know
something I don't do
and then when I was approached about
doing a think Oh
when I was approached about doing Tommy
Lee goes to college um
hold on the idea that like look we're
taking this rock star
out of the his element and we're gonna
throw him in the like middle America
first of all I never went to college I
didn't graduate high school I quit I
quit my senior year I got a recording
contract and I was like how far ends in
your songs right here oh don't go rock
the world let me think about that
[ __ ] that I'm out so I just officially
graduated everybody I remember my
parents going my god you only have three
months ago just finish school what if
this music thing doesn't work out I'm
like oh it's gonna work out so this is
like I'm like so they're like we're
gonna stick you in the middle of middle
America people are gonna bug the [ __ ]
out that a you're going to college and
I'm thinking I never did get a chance to
go to college and I heard about rowdy
college parties and [ __ ] that's a
college town and I'm thinking yeah you
know what this could be really [ __ ] up
in a fun weird way I'd get to check out
a semester of college see what it's like
and and freak some people out so why not
and so ended up doing the show and yes I
was put to put to the test in did the
party and got that in people never let
you not do that and weird like and I
partied like a maniac and I hadn't
really know about keg stand and like
college party and [ __ ] like you know
pretty fun but but it was frustrating
man it was crazy because um you know I
did like what are you a horticulture was
one of them which I love I I think I was
a plant and in a past life I just
naturally
like I can we could walk outside now and
I can tell you what the botanical name
of that tree is really where I'd got
that information up from I don't know
that's why I must have been a plant um I
took what did I take [ __ ] chemistry I'm
like our chemistry is gonna be dope oh
so you did get to pick your class yeah
yeah I thought they just assigned them
no you know they let you be a real
student they yeah okay yeah all right
all chemistry dude I'm just picturing
beakers explosions [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
right okay so and of course music so
let's go rock the drum corps um what
else all physics or some [ __ ] I was like
oh okay let's do this
way out of my league way out of my
league but anyway the music portion I
was like oh this is gonna be dope cuz I
did drum corps marching band in high
school and junior high school so I'm
thinking this is gonna be like she's a
cake on just but just on a college level
this is big and it was everything I just
did not expect I was completely
overwhelmed with you know I had learned
in school how to read music playing
piano but never really drum saw you on
at home so you don't [ __ ] like that drum
ice drumming I taught myself okay um so
I didn't never really did the technical
sheet music drum stuff so now I got this
[ __ ] whipped out in front of me and I
got a drum captain my buddy Ben and he's
just looking at me I'm looking at this
[ __ ] like it's Greek and I'm Greek and I
could don't understand it and I'm like
dude I am I'm lost I have no idea what's
happening here
and he's just looking at me was just
shaking his head like you're [ __ ]
Tommy Lee you don't know yeah you don't
understand I play by feel by it you know
it's inside me it comes out I don't read
it off paper and then play it you know
so this is a totally different animal
and man the frustration insane insane
you got all these drummers and they're
all badasses like they got they got
chops they're not rock chops they're not
drumset chops but there
rudimental like limpid these double
double triple stroke rolls fladoodles
just the all this crazy [ __ ] so that was
a really frustrating thing for me as a
drummer just to be pretty much knocked
back down to like hey here's this is a
whole other side of drumming that you
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing yeah that's good I loved it though
it's cool how are you great um not so
good not so good but at that so I get
try I try I try like I tried like a
[ __ ] I did well in horticulture
I was gonna say I bet you did do good
that um in in and I had a tutor who was
cute that was a good part of it so I did
enjoy I did enjoy the sort of after
hours studying yes yes yeah yeah but I
wonder why your grades suffered yeah so
yeah I mean it was cool it was really a
cool experience you know I look back on
it now and I'm like I'm glad I did that
and they got a chance to see also the
real side like you said yeah personal
side of somebody who's you know
frustrated in you know I'm wanting to be
professional and taking it seriously and
you're just hot dogging it for a [ __ ]
TV show so many people just go on TV to
be on TV like you were like if I'm gonna
do this I'm really gonna do this yeah
and it came across and I was like [ __ ]
yes is a good show that's cool yeah I
loved it so let's go back to the
beginning you're a Greek boy so you were
born in Greece born in Athens Greece yet
and then you moved here when how
almost to OKC I I grew up with Greek
guys in Baltimore and I was saying they
said this on an episode before
everything was melaka oh I like
everything everything everything I was
like Jesus Christ you guys say and then
you know he talked about it's like jerk
off and everything else good
everything was melaka but their dad
owned this it was in West Baltimore -
was in the it was in a rough
neighborhood
they were Greek immigrants they would do
the whole lamb in the backyard the only
thing for Easter and all that [ __ ] like
in there you are just right aful so it's
so great style dude but he had a like a
pizza sub shop and we would go on
deliveries and deliver them all around
the city and then he would just give us
food but his [ __ ] was the best oh man
yeah that marinate that lamb for like
almost two days yeah that's great yeah
that there's no Joe so both your mom and
dad are Greek then no no my mom full
full-blown Greek father American okay
they're both gone god bless him but yeah
my father met my mom in the when he was
stationed okay her in the army and they
got married had me and then we moved to
Los Angeles and I was pretty much
growing up here okay my whole life so so
then who was the person or what was the
thing that got you into specifically
drumming I was it hearing it in some
music or was your dad into it mom into
it my dad actually played played some
drums in sin in school in the marching
band although he didn't really he didn't
you don't really like teach me drums it
was weird from what my parents said as
soon as I was tall enough probably like
you know wow you're between the ages of
1 or 1 & 2 URI I'm able to start while
walking around and open him and closing
cabinets
I they said as soon as I was able to
kind of get into [ __ ]
so I'm assuming around two two years old
I was pulling out pots pans boxes
anything and just wail and I just they
just said you just started playing on
everything that made noise my poor
parents I must have driven them crazy
but it worked
[ __ ] picked up [ __ ] flute or
something why the drums they're so
supportive though man I really had some
super dope supportive parents my dad
who's a mechanic in services and also
for the LA County Road department
serious mechanic gave up for a man who's
a mechanic to give up his his man cave
which was the garage with all of his
tools and [ __ ] he gave it up he gave me
three quarters of it analyst left enough
room for his tools and all his [ __ ] and
he built me a soundproof room inside the
garage was a room inside of a room a he
didn't want to hear it yeah you know and
but he did want you to play but he
wanted me to play and also keeping you
home on the drums is keeping you off the
streets true you know even though you
still find the streets he's keeping you
off the streets a lot less yeah but he
was so supportive dude this is how how
crazy supportive fun you know what your
dad's name David David all right yeah
and he being mechanic mechanical
engineer guy um but I but you know but
we put together that's our first like
little band and we're like playing like
high school dances and [ __ ] like that
and we're like we need a like [ __ ] man
we need like a lighting system and we
need like pyrotechnics dude we need fire
like wait what was that band's name do
you remember it was called u.s. 101
yeah man what are we go call ourselves
how we get here tonight the one I want
you order 101 for us 101
dude my dad gets these blocks he's like
two by four blocks drills holes through
them puts these metal like kind of like
the prongs through them there they're
wired to a switcher box now you got
these prongs coming up with a little
like kind of guitar string wire yeah
right and as soon as you and then the
steel pipe he'd cut like a mortar for
high schoolish it would launch right and
you set it on over the prongs fill them
up with a couple of caps of gunpowder
yeah yeah and he's got the switcher
boxing we're in my we're in my backyard
okay and this is like we're wearing do
you live in California v 'no i know i
know kobe you know well so we got me
there's neighbors we're all right you
know we middle-class family urban you
know I mean really like small
neighborhood and and there's explosions
happen and in the backyard my dad's
testing the [ __ ] he's like we're in my
backyard like boom I mean he was so into
it he's like a little cute like a little
kid yeah so he's making pyro then he
built he built like a chopper down in
the service totally dude garnished it
was coming out best time man what'd you
figure out a way if you didn't play an
instrument you're like I want to be
involved in it doesn't if I could help
my kid like in Duke and do whatever I
could to make it super badass for all I
would and I that you're so lucky to have
a dad like that dude blessed so you
would you would dude backyard shows back
in the day it yeah oh yeah be oh yeah
all the time backyard parties so let me
ask a little parties because you said
David Lee and then made David Lee Roth
popping - my father had real fast but
I'm a friend of mine told me her
brother's older than we are and said
that they used to play because they came
up out here obviously as well but he
used to go see them at backyard parties
back in the day sort of as they were
forming van Halen do you you guys would
play back I mean so there are people out
there that saw Tommy Lee play a backyard
highschool party in Covina California oh
yeah all over the place that's awesome
all over the place in Vince my singer
motley horse he was in a car he was in a
cover band called rock candy doing the
same thing backyard kegger parties so
people had seen us doing that kind of
stuff and one day putting together
motley I'm like man I went to school
we're looking for a singer we're looking
for a singer and I'm like I know this
dude man all the chicks love this dude
like he's he goes to my school he's
[ __ ] dope lookin has a killer voice
sings awesome cheap trick covers and
like just like and you know he's just
he's just killer I think we should odd
to we should grab them and so we stole
him out of his band and he came an
audition for motley and the rest is kind
of history I mean we were doing the same
thing same age doing the same the four
of you yeah at that age so people saw
the original motley crew at backyard
parties wells everyone in at that time
everyone everyone was in a band doing
something okay at that time yeah and
then you all came together and boom yeah
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor upstart during
these economically turbulent times
everyone's looking for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still needlessly throwing money every
month at high interest credit card debt
it's time you checked out upstart the
revolutionary online lending platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score now is the time to find out
how low your upstart rate can be to help
pay off high interest credit card debt
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or a diploma to
apply though upstart lets you skip going
to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from $1,000 to $50,000 so
you can consolidate your debt into one
easy fixed-rate payment upstart makes it
fast and simple to check your rate since
it's just a soft pool it won't affect
your credit score the hard pull happens
if you accept your rate and proceed with
your application and the best part is if
the loan is approved and accepted most
people get their funds the very next
business day over 400,000 people have
used up start to pay off credit cards or
meet their financial goals free yourself
from the burden of high interest credit
card debt and get back to using your
money your way with up start cy up
starter has a 4 point 9 out of 5 rating
on Trustpilot
and hurry to up start calm / honeydew to
find out how low your up start rate can
be checking your rate only takes a few
minutes
that's upstart calm / honeydew our next
sponsor is Ray Con so whether you're
working from home or working on your
fitness you want what you're listening
to to be what you're listening to not
what your friends listening to your kids
are listening to the person next to you
is listening - everyone needs a gray
pair of wireless earbuds but before you
go drop in hundreds of dollars on a pair
you need to check out the wireless
earbuds from Ray Khan
look I use rip my rake on earbuds I use
them all the time I well I was traveling
with them I still use them to exercise I
use them around the house I use them for
calls honestly they're my favorite
earbuds I've ever had
you already know ray con earbuds started
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
and then they sound just as amazing as
other top audio brands that you know but
their newest model the everyday e
25-year buds are their best ones yet
with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are so comfortable they're
perfect for conference calls or binging
podcasts like the honeydew and the
honeydew with y'all unlike some of your
other wireless options ray con earbuds
are both stylish and discreet with no
dangling wires or stems to distract
anyone during video
you've heard me talk about how the
company was co-founded by Ray J and
celebrities like snoop cardi B brandy
they're all obsessed with Ray Khan so
pick up a pair and see what the hype is
all about now's the time to get the
latest and greatest from recon get 15%
off your order at buy rake on Comm slash
honeydew that's bu why rake on comm /
honeydew for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds buy rake on comm / honeydew now
let's get back to the do I mean I I just
you know when I got livewire the first
time I was like Jesus I want to ask you
cuz on what the show is just it's just
one it's it's one I it sticks with me
every time it comes on right it is a
good one man it's so [ __ ] raw is that
it is about a real friend right is that
or is it loosely about someone loosely
yeah that's such a great [ __ ] it is
that's it's a great melody man I love
that one your [ __ ] is so [ __ ] and
it's got that on what am I thinking of
Orbison Roy Orbison and that if that
beat got got got got got got for some
reason that's just like that beat works
on just about anything man it just I
don't know what it is about it it's just
it just drives it's one of those beats
and so on with the show that oh it's so
good - and then obviously on and on and
on but the thing that always I liked
about you - you had the Mighty Mouse
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and and we were
talking about underdog and the underdogs
and you're a big fan obviously of the
underdog so this show is really all
about the underdog so one of the things
I love that you said is that you put a
lot of people that are unknown on the
new album yes record you keep saying
record I keep saying album yep is there
a difference hell no okay
same thing you can accept whatever the
fact that we're dating ourselves by
saying record an album yeah I guess
but not so much man Bono's making a
massive back you're right so a lot of
comics so we're cool yeah we are cool
but now I can say out leaves that I can
say albums what
so who some of the artists that you have
on that you really like and how do you
find them you know cuz we talk about
comics they all you know there's a good
community of comedians that pull each
other up which is really fantastic and
that's what you're talking about doing
with musicians and but you also are
finding people from all genres of music
I love that about that's cool that
comedians do that and I'm I'm a big
underdog fan and do the same thing I'll
just Bob just I'll find for some reason
well I'm a [ __ ] magnet but for something
[ __ ] [ __ ] just get 5/5 yeah but I'm
all I'm not but I'm also like you know
I've done another kind of magnet where
I'd for some reason I'll it'll find me
or a hog gravitates towards something
that's that draws me beat wise or style
wise or sonically and I'll be like oh
that's dope
no one [ __ ] knows about it just and I
have a collaboration list of people that
I want to collaborate with and I'll find
people I'll find them on the internet
all somebody will turn me on to
something that find something else you
know you go down a rabbit hole of stuff
anyway so as I'm making and Rose I'm
making the record you know I'll have a
track and I'm like oh my god this person
would absolutely murder this track and
so let's say knock me down that's out
now for instance is that literally the
one I saw the video Britney knock
pulling you out of the [ __ ] chair
that knocked me down
yes it is it's the first time I've ever
seen this mega rock star look like every
other married husband out there cool
John Legere yeah it looked like it hurt
like a [ __ ] and you were just
like and you - oh my god there it just
got yourself back up
she's banging back that's how we are she
she's [ __ ] crazy to end violent yeah
yeah yeah I don't like to make your wife
laughs she's one of those punchers dude
we talked about it I know [ __ ] like I'm
like that hurt yeah she's like silent
laughs with that and then yeah
ready what's your [ __ ] job all the
time just or or it just hits you hard
yes yeah sorry
I think Sunnyside yeah thanks Brit well
at least she does not only to meet you
everybody does good was they oh the
underdog yes and that is the track I
just hit him up
hit him up on Instagram and and wow you
just straight reached out like that yeah
well in the the funny story is he told
me later he's like got a message from me
a DM from me and he's like I wouldn't
believe it he goes oh this is some fake
Tommy Lee account [ __ ] Tommy Lee job
yeah right and then he looked it up and
he's like oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's
him and he hit me back he's like dude
yes [ __ ] what's going on I said let me
send you this track this track has
regime and you had never met this guy
never met a [ __ ] you but I heard his
[ __ ] and now with Instagram and social
media you're one step away instead of
having to get your your rep or your
manager to find this person to govern
take three months to get a guy on the
[ __ ] phone yeah I know yeah if not
long right [ __ ] ridiculous huh so I
hit him up he's like god damn so I sent
him the track I was like dude I just I
just track has your name all over it
he's like he heard he goes done a day
two days later he lives up north he's up
my house and we bang the truck out same
with the other track tops with push push
I've been following her for a couple of
years wat just watching her listening to
her I dig her style everything same
thing I got this super sexy sea
you know dance kind of electric electro
soundtrack reached out to her sent it to
her she's like oh man
this is [ __ ] about us I'll let me at
it and same thing over to the studio
done and that's been kind of the theme
here with you know people I've wanted to
collaborate with or you know him you
know just just found randomly pretty
much everybody there's the only I'm
trying to think the only person that's
on the record that anyone might know is
his name's Lucas Rossi and he was in he
was the singer for a show I did on NBC
called I don't know if you remember it's
called rock star supernova where yeah
yeah yeah we crew we were looking it was
me uh Gilby from Guns and Roses he'll
chase right yeah yo Clark Jason Newsted
from Metallica and myself when we were
looking for a singer of that that was
the premise of the show and we picked
Lucas out of everybody we did a record
with him and stuff anyway Lucas makes an
appearance on the record so that's one
of the names people might recognize we
did a prints cover that's [ __ ] insane
he's insane can you say what song the
song is called when you were mine oh
yeah which is typically kinda bad yeah
which is typically kind of happy like
when you yeah it's not definitely
popping up being well we slowed we
slowed this [ __ ] down and it is a [ __ ]
song man I'm telling you it'll be proud
it is sell dude he would you be like why
didn't I think of that yeah it's just
it's just it's downtempo it's super sexy
and Lucas sings the [ __ ] out of it and
it so that might be one that you'd
recognize everybody else on Oh another
guy Pavan he's from a group called the
Foreign Beggars big big
you rap guys out of the out of the UK
but other than Mickey Avalon Mickey
Avalon is another one people with no
Brooke candy Brooke candy yep there's a
there's a there's some people that won't
you'll know and there's some underdogs
that you won't know but so I asked you
earlier before we were recording had you
ever auditioned for a band and been cut
or anything you were like I got pretty
[ __ ] lucky so what are like I did
audition once on [ __ ] frying on
mushrooms and I thought I thought I
thought for sure I wasn't gonna make
that but they dug me I I got hired I
just from there all everyone was like
yeah let's do some mushrooms like all
right and I don't think it I don't think
I had ever done any so I'm thinking oh
what the [ __ ]
all right sure and so we're doing we do
them now probably about 20 minutes goes
by we're hanging out talking oh my god
well let's let's go play and I'm pretty
cool as we start but as now the [ __ ]
much the shrooms are kicking in and dude
everything starts to [ __ ] get super
glitchy on me like everything's like and
I'm like what the [ __ ] is hat like I'd
I've just buggin out and I'm like dudes
I can't I can't do this like I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] high as [ __ ] and and everybody
was high in there like ended up getting
the gig
I don't know how cuz I could barely
somehow I was playing but in my mind and
my eyes did not look like what was
happening they might have been on ass
and thought it sounded amazing it would
everyone was caught it was great
everyone was high and it was like that
you know it sounded like some Grateful
Dead [ __ ] and they were like well this
is dope he's cool he's he can stay I
wanted to tell you oh okay I can't
believe I get to tell you this story
because this is burned in my brain so I
want to see you guys
probably early 2000s at the forum mmm
who came back on tour I was hoping he
would do the whole rig and you did and
everything but I grew up in Maryland so
you know heavy metal parking lot I'm
sure you know that video okay there
those kids are a little older than me
but same people you know those kids had
kids oh yeah I'm that generate I got you
and cap centers where we would go to the
dead shows and stuff if if that's
whenever if you wanted drugs that's
where you would go get it the Dead come
to town we go to the parking lot so
everybody's getting their opium their
weed their acid or whatever some peanut
butter and jellies whatever drug salad
right totally so I grew up with the
heads and the dirts and all the
headbangers and the hair metal guys and
I loved all that music too and I go to
see you guys at the forum and I get to
the parking lot and it's like 1980 all
over again I'm like oh my god it was
like all those people came from wherever
the [ __ ] they live in Southern
California and collected a dismal
parking lot it was Camaros and
everything else it was the best so I was
like this is a [ __ ] straight-up
flashback so there's there's this drunk
chick this white big fat girl and she's
trying to fistfight people and she is
just rowdy as [ __ ] she's fired she's one
of those people you're like oh man you
ain't gonna make it through the show
today it's like one o'clock yeah they're
trying to fight guys right but have
where yeah I have bacon bash and wearing
these she's so big she's wearing snow
boots you know like the cheap vinyl ones
you could get a Kmart that her navy blue
with like snowflakes on them and have
that lace no that's what she's wearing
right oh so we we go in whatever show
started and if if you've ever sat in the
forum the old forum when you sit on the
end row the stairs come down like you
can rest your elbow on the steps oh here
I'll show oh we know what I mean it's
not elevator yeah and I'm high as [ __ ]
and of course you know when your course
I'm gonna do you guys right you know
when your eye just turns into a camera
and I get that close-up look and I just
hear something coming down this because
you go down I hear something coming down
the stairs and I hear this boom and I
look over and there's the [ __ ] boot
and it's her he's coming down our oh hey
what you got up in that [ __ ] rig man
it's so it's crazy it's his whoa
was that the one where us flying from
drumming yeah yeah you're all out of
being intent are you are you full of
sins - I think it was I think those
carnival sounds like early 2000s like
yeah three four somewhere in there
yeah yep that's probably the one dude
have you ever messed up onstage to a
point where you it's so noticeable
you're just like he not messed up as in
like [ __ ] up apart but messed up as in
and God gotten [ __ ] really really
hurt several times from doing that yeah
you have yeah what happened
hold on Hartford Connecticut dr.
feelgood tore the drums are 60 yeah
they're way up to 70 feet high going all
the way out over the audience's head to
the person and the [ __ ] back of the
arena no you're right here that person
yeah that's a Stevie Wonder section but
no one could know we're so far right
before they had the big scream while
back that name yeah yeah yeah they were
just just starting to happen but like
there's shitty seats so my objective for
that whole drum thing was I'm gonna make
the person in the [ __ ] shittiest seat
in this place have a front row ticket so
I'm doing this the drums go all the way
out to the back there wrote a in and
they're coming back once the things over
I step off like I I step off the drum
kit and I put my foot in a you know
strapped it's like a bungee cord and I
just I let go or I just jump on and go
and rip kind of repel and there's a guy
down below with the handbrake and he
stopped he hits the brake sooner they
just get right to the ground
sure okay yeah well I'm doing this and
this isn't Hartford I'll never forget it
I'm doing it and I I don't feel the
handbrake kick in and I'm like oh [ __ ]
something something's something wrong so
I just decide I pull my foot out of the
strap and I figure I better get my foot
out of the strap and just sort of like
if I can just kind of eject here maybe I
can get and try to land like a cat or
something
because this is gonna get [ __ ] really
yeah your legs are gonna go up your ass
I don't know what's I don't know all I
know is I got to get out because this
isn't cool
and so I I wanted to get out and just
the heel part of my foot was still in
the rope and slam my head on the
concrete of the arena floor out
concussion ow damn show's over I wake up
and in the ambulance and there was the
last thing you remember that the fall
was was just was jumping off and nothing
else and nothing else so did you make it
back to the stage I what they came and
got me I woke up in the ambulance and I
was like what happened they're like I'll
dude take it easy you just you just had
a crazy crazy fall I'm like oh [ __ ] I
gotta get I gotta get back there we're
gonna [ __ ] show them he's a finisher
right and they're like no no no dude no
that's a negative so yeah I had a
concussion and spent the next two days
in
for recuperating in somebody you know
when you have a concussion you're not
supposed to go back to sleep so somebody
just keeping me awake yeah day and a
half or so and back at it but that and
the tour you saw when I was flying from
drum kit to drum kit at the very end of
the last time of this last kit on cue in
my ears we have a inaudible saying three
two and on one I [ __ ] I I get yanked
from a harness off of it the lights go
black and it looks like I get blown off
the thing and I'm again I'm just gone in
the dark like your dad's out there with
his pirates
yeah there's this like you know it's
like a stunt thing you know those
harnesses that pull you look like well
the lights go black so you don't want
people to see you getting blown off you
just want to just be blow up but when
they're black like that can you see
anything
yeah so 3 2 1 is a blackout for the
lighter lighting director the lights go
black
I get yanked in the dark and the ship
blows to pieces right well I get the
audible cue and it's lights go black I
don't get yank oh and I just take a
[ __ ] damn would have been perfect no
island no eyelashes no eyebrows you
can't move you don't there's nothing oh
my I can't jump I'm connected the thing
that didn't work and it sound like I
just want this just took the hit so the
second third-degree burns down my hands
holy it was just a bad luck so no not
embarrassing as in like a man you [ __ ]
that part up
just embarrassing moments of like really
[ __ ] yourself up yeah that's scary
shits that could be death yeah uh and
ooh I'm a bit of a thrill seeker I kind
of I'm gonna like it otherwise I
wouldn't [ __ ] keep doing it all right
do you have you skydive you bungee all
that stuff yeah what's the would you
bungee jump again
oh yeah in a second I'm trying to get my
wife to go she's like there's no way I'm
going listen we're going to Australia to
play this year I'm not sorry next year
next summer the tour and I'm taking you
New Zealand's got one of the highest
spots you can jump for him I think it's
I want to say four or five hundred [ __ ]
that she's like oh hell no I'm not no
we're going you are going I'm we're
gonna get over this fear and we're going
so yeah I love all that [ __ ] Six Flags
Magic I love them I love amusement park
roller like I'm a [ __ ] junkie I had
anything to get scared and just you know
have a little poo poo in your pants like
I'm down with that
I got a whole bit about Tatsu that
[ __ ] roller coaster at Six Flags
almost [ __ ] myself on that [ __ ] we
had a weed brownie before we went on it
was all but that's a gnarly one though
it is that's the advancement in roller
to coastal I say all the time like it
from from this I remember we used to go
to Kings Dominion in Richmond Richmond
Virginia from that was the closest one
to us and it was a big park eventually
paramount bought it there's like a Kings
Island I think in Ohio and I use the oh
yeah I think that's their like sister
like Busch Gardens and [ __ ] like that
you know just yeah and it was called the
rebel yell and it was an old wooden
coaster just like the one that was out
here forever
Colossus Colossus rickety rickety is
[ __ ] neck and then it would go
backwards I was like perfect thing
yeah then we had the one called the King
Cobra that you just start at the top and
then you did one loop and that was it
you went back and it was done now
they're trying to rip your [ __ ] out
of these want these things oh yeah and
you know they're loving it
let's see how close we can get to before
these guys [ __ ] themselves
just below chunks it's not if they
didn't blow chunks that the the the
rollercoaster architecture like we
failed miserably [ __ ] and we're not yeah
[ __ ] themselves and puking then with
people shut themselves today yeah I
don't want to ask you because you're a
big guy how tall are you 6 was 6 - were
you did you ever get in fights were you
a fighter a lot or were you the guy that
could because you're also funny could
you talk your way out of it that's a lot
of comedians I mean I've gotten a lot of
fights though yeah I mean I I love to
scrap me too especially especially you
know I don't know yet as soon as you
start drinking Jack Daniels or tequila
someone will just look at me and I'll be
able to [ __ ] you looking at like and
they didn't even say right yeah knows I
can actually checking out the menu buy
the [ __ ] [ __ ] skirt shit-stirrer you
know just add alcohol and like here we
go I loved I loved that's fun it's just
fun just to [ __ ] scrap out especially
when you're with a couple of buddies cuz
then you feel like it a little bit more
of it yeah for sure me and you know and
my my bros are gonna kick your ass right
but yeah good fights fun so alright can
we talk about marriage
sure alright you've been married three
times yeah what what makes you keep
going back did you ever let me ask you
this did you ever think you'd be married
a third time after number two did you
think you'd be married a third time no
no I didn't I was like you know
everything that just don't I'm just not
meant to be married I didn't [ __ ] why
why am I not getting it right no it's
not the right partnership what the
[ __ ] what you know marriage doesn't
come with a manual it's not like you
know it's just
yeah and it's a lot of work you know
they just don't magically just work
right so yes to answer your question no
I was just kind of like you know [ __ ] me
I'm just gonna be single forever
you know maybe that's maybe that's what
I was supposed to do I'm not coming the
gun a guy who's never home anyway I'm
always on tour yeah what's the point
well you know it's like owning a house
I'm like why do I even have a house I'm
never [ __ ] at it but that all changed
when I met Brittany another quick break
to tell you about our next sponsor Oh
max cryofreeze living with chronic pain
is the worst it's more than a feeling of
discomfort it can affect your whole life
many of my listeners probably have some
type of pain that has prevented you guys
from relaxing and sleeping or stopped
you from exercising perhaps it's been
ongoing for a few weeks now and hasn't
improved with any of the treatments
you've tried enter Oh max health if
you're looking to get rid of nagging
muscle and joint pain immediately while
providing long lasting recovery then you
need to try the natural breakthrough
pain relief solution cryofreeze CBD
roll-on developed by Oh max health this
non-prescription triple action pain
relief roll-on is specially formulated
to block pain receptors reduce
inflammation and improve muscle and
joint flexibility the best part is this
100% natural CBD powered remedy works
its magic within ten minutes of
application and relief lasts up to eight
hours much longer than the
over-the-counter products look I use
this all the time I use the roll-on I've
been telling you about it on my neck and
shoulder right here I've been using it
my buddy Eric Abrams
what's up Abrams hit me up I was like
dude give me the real deal
well I did and guess what chronic user
now chronic user all up and down here
man it helps so much tight muscles
nagging injuries all that stuff I
promise you this stuff works Oh max
health is offering my listeners 20% off
of a full body cryofreeze CBD pain
relief roll-on plus free shipping this
discount also applies toward any product
site-wide so here's what you got to do
go to Omax health.com today enter code
honeydew that's oma ex health.com and
enter code honeydew to get 20% off
cryofreeze
and site-wide our next sponsor
supporting the honeydew is manse key
two is the best amends below-the-belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
they obsess over their technology
developments to provide you the best
tools for your grooming experience look
I've used some of these other trimmers
before and I mean my taint was tattered
okay all bloodied up chopped up and I
couldn't you talking about
that's why manscape has redesigned the
electric trimmer the manscaped
engineering team spent 18 months
perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created and just released
the new and approved lawn mower 3.0 all
right that's a great way to spend 18
months their third generation trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce manscaping accidents
thanks to man escapes advanced skin safe
technology when I tell you this is
premium I mean its premium all right
this battery will last up to 90 minutes
so you can take a longer shave some of
you after this quarantine are gonna need
up to 90 minutes man escapes gotcha the
water resistant technology allows you to
groom in the shower one of the coolest
features is the LED light which
illuminates grooming areas for a closer
and more precise trimming they've also
upgraded to a 7000 rpm motor with quiet
stroke technology and let's not forget
about the charging stand show your mower
off loud and proud because the
intelligently designed stand is a
convenient charging dock powered by USB
if you are listening to me speak right
now I want you to experience it
firsthand for yourself trim that junk of
yours get 20% off and free shipping with
the code honeydew at manscaped calm your
balls will thank you 20% off and free
shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape calm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscaped calm and use code
honeydew now let's get back to the do
just [ __ ] just the craziest thing and
it's almost embarrassing to say but I
[ __ ] met her I had followed her for
[ __ ] years on vine and
let's talk Brittany is vine you know
yeah yeah yeah it's like exactly
Brittany is [ __ ] vine like I didn't
even know about vine I was like give me
Brittany
they're like yeah at the time yeah she's
fine yeah [ __ ] fine yeah cuz I bust
their balls all time I'm like heather
locklear Pam Anderson Britney for Allah
[Music]
I feel bad she hears that dumb that
Jesus [ __ ] all the time he's with it so
wait you got you guy you followed her on
vine you were on vines yep four years
your isn't all of it you got your finger
dialed in on [ __ ] yeah and I and I
followed her it was like she's super
[ __ ] funny she's hot as [ __ ] and and
anyway I'm just my kids that are 24 and
almost 23 or like you know I'm single
just still like kind of dating here and
there blah blah blah just doing the
thing and having fun and all but I'm
just nothing nothing seriously they're
like dad you need to get on this app
this is my [ __ ] kids telling me this
you need to get on this app it's called
Riya and I was like the [ __ ] is Riya
there like it's all like people like you
dad like it's just a sex it's only like
you know actors or athletes or they're
only like professionals on there
musicians like da da da da da no Stevie
Nicks is on there people like you and
you got to get vetted and you got to get
approved like you've second there just
there's just not everybody's on their
[ __ ] whatever right so I'm like
alright wow you were willing to do it I
was alright good for you man boys advice
yeah why not see what they're talking
about so I get on the thing it's like I
don't know two weeks goes by and I get
the you've been whatever the [ __ ] it is
certified approved whatever and I was
like oh cool so I'm flipping around on
here and I'm like no way that
[ __ ] on here what and I'm just
I'm bum buggin out like and all these
people are mixed
[ __ ] singles right yeah and looking
fine look yeah right and I [ __ ] all
the sudden there's like get the [ __ ] out
Britney I see Britney and I'm like no
[ __ ] way and I'm like hey it's you
know it's Tommy um and then you know
that's legit because you're on a service
that's been vetted so if they hit you up
it's that person yeah this is the real
deal right and some being Kathy yeah I
think I invited her to I was playing a
la pride thing with Brooke candy
I was playing drums and my buddy from
Danny Lohner from Nine Inch Nails
playing guitar for her we did this thing
at the la pride and I said like that
probably might be a cool place to meet
you know you know because I'm not really
cool with a little like one-on-one weird
thing like hey so nice to meet you so
I'm like thinking it's a good spot she
[ __ ] shows up with she first of all
I'm looking everywhere for I don't
[ __ ] see her I know she looks like
I'm looking for this [ __ ] pretty
brunette girl right nothing I'm thinking
[ __ ] she blew me off with the [ __ ] and I
get a tap on the shoulder I turn around
and I'm like is this [ __ ] she's
wearing a [ __ ] clown wig this is this
big you know like multi-cut you know get
like the rainbow colors yeah for pride
right and she's like it's the first
meeting so I'm like okay I see well you
got that you got the real person right
yeah yeah and I'm like and we suck so
it's been it's been all love ever since
madness really seemed like she makes me
laugh and you know what dudes laughter
is priceless it keeps you young
- bro I keep you young it makes when you
face her a lot I mean I see it makes her
back hurt a lot - money out of your
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude yeah
I know I know every [ __ ] day is
something with her yes you know her yeah
but you know her way different than idea
telling some story what's the red worms
you were taught story before we started
I think she's like a closet
exhibitionist she doesn't do it to
everybody although she she [ __ ] for
some reason wants to share her I call
them red worms when she has you know
that that time of the month
hmm she'll she'll [ __ ] take pictures
of of this I mean for or she'll just
[ __ ] she'll just come out just bring
the panties in and be like oh my God
look and I am so I have such a weak
stomach dude I'm immediately I'll throw
up and I have getting teary eyed right
now
oh yeah disgusting and and and I don't
know what it is with her she likes to
share that with me maybe she because she
wants to see me throw up
maybe and I maybe that's maybe that's
the man but then she'll send me pictures
over poof - and I'm like and like and
and I'm like why I don't understand why
are you saying why are you sending me a
picture of your poop and dude it's a put
I wish I it's a poop like it's coming
out of the water like like by this lunch
I'm like that came out that came out
after [ __ ] once a month as I'm gagging
I'm like is that what is that that's
Ghostly like dressing could not come out
of this little tiny thing Jesus she put
it this way we share everything clear
literally but you said something that
blew me away you said you had never seen
that No
all no has so I mean I've you know of
course
I was telling you like the first time I
never slate as a man you get an
education on women going through life
and hopefully you do meet one that can
tell you like look man this is what it's
really [ __ ] like and I remember
having sex with a girl on her period and
when we were done I looked down and
there's a [ __ ] I didn't know what it
was I thought it was like it looked like
a purple bloody leech and my my knees
buckled and I was like huh what the [ __ ]
is that are you okay and she's like oh
it's just a clot and wiped it off like
it was dust no baby like it was nothing
I was like and then I went up and
showered and I just remember looking
down and seeing blood I was like similar
I'm gonna do all had that kind of a
thing but these are extra big I don't
know record [ __ ] it's crazy I mean I've
had that kind of experience we're like
you're eating a girl's [ __ ] I'm in the
hotel room and you've ordered [ __ ]
more [ __ ] rose' or whatever and just
[ __ ] room service guys at the door
and I've answered the door just looked
like [ __ ] axe murderer reason from
eating [ __ ] in this line you don't you
don't know it but there's [ __ ] work
there's blood all over your face and
groups like this thinkin somebody's died
so I'm the pink see we've all had those
experiences but but her I don't know
it's a it's is it into roses
endometriosis it just it's it's it's
wild yeah I had a girl named just Danner
who was on the honeydew with you all
talking to us and Jeff stone is she had
these crazy health problems and it
wrapped around her insides and she had
to have all these special surgery I mean
we're lucky we are
every day I'm so glad I'm a guy I'd be
the worst woman anyway I'd be like I'd
be if I'd be a pig I'd be just I
wouldn't take care of myself like I'll
cut those doughnuts ya know they man it
bless all here's two here's
dudes I mean and here's the women bless
them too but thank you but as the damn
they got a lot of [ __ ] to deal with they
do fine these days the way they got a I
mean I couldn't afford I couldn't afford
my hair if I was a woman oh my god oh my
god dude this has been seriously thank
you so much it's been so much fun oh
thank you for coming on please again
promote everything the album not
everything you want tour whatever
jeez I hate doing that stuff but do it
okay I'm here and Rho new tommy lee
record uh october 15th is the release of
the entire record the singles are out
now tops and hold knock me down are out
on pretty much all formats Spotify Apple
music blah blah blah pretty much
everywhere you get music and the videos
are out and I can't wait for everyone to
hear the whole record yeah yeah and and
the reason for that being is like I'm I
hate [ __ ] filler tracks
I [ __ ] they will not be there not on
my on my projects I just I despise those
like I whatever it's there's there's
three good ones that's enough um so
that's what I'm excited for people to
hear the whole record because the whole
record really is a banger and in that
that's the reason I released two singles
at once people don't typically do that I
wanted people to hear get a vibe for
what the records like right here's a
male and a male and a female energy
track so I think that gives basically a
good representation of what to expect on
the record so go out and get it cuz yeah
it is man I'm [ __ ] stoked agree or I
love you still doing it do it and then
the tours now move because everything to
2021 is at 2021 yeah we just released
the I'm coming to see you in LA no
you're definitely coming you're coming
as my guest I'm bringing that chick with
the boots too bro dude we got food we
gonna find her
thank you again thank you my awesome as
always Ryan Sickler comm Ryan Sickler
all social media will talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]